néctar
arroba love comector
10 versus 1 10 mujeres eligen Quién es
compatible para él las citas son
competitivas Pero y si se vuelve un
esfuerzo de equipo reunimos a diez
mujeres quienes saldrán con el mismo
chico y decidirán quién de ellas es la
más compatible con él
[Música]
un placer conocernos
Gracias lo nombraremos hoy aún no tiene
nombre reconocen a Melvin estuvo en este
episodio la última temporada pero las
cosas no salieron bien y regresó por la
revancha bien chicas si les agrada
Melvin y quieren seguir jugando quédense
en su lugar
Si no es así pueden irse ahora
excelente
cómo te sientes Melvin mejor
hora del cóctel
muy bien quién sirve los tragos en
realidad no entonces
alguien quiere sidra Hoy soy el
cantinero
muy bien Qué es lo que más te gusta de
ti creo que soy muy bueno con los
chistes de papá
como llamas a un gato sin piernas qué
carne picada
está bien está bien cómo llamas a una
vaca con tres piernas
salud salud
les gusta ver películas
cuál es tu favorita cuál es tu favorita
película favorita
muy divertida te gusta Marvel desde
luego
favorito el Hombre Araña
Por cierto
a mí también No esa película fue hecha
para la mirada femenina así que me
alegra
algún amor platónico hay una golfista se
llama Lily Hill y es muy hermosa es una
celebridad Si ves esto
reunimos a 10 chicas
No me maten estás estudiando actualmente
sí estoy estudiando me especializo en
relaciones públicas en la universidad de
California y también en programación
informática qué bien Cuáles son tus
hobbies Bueno me dedico a fotografía y
haya hecho algunas sesiones muy bonitas
has estado en alguna relación Sí claro
Dinos cuánto tiempo Y cómo te fue
y Cómo terminó Sí
[Música]
bueno lo que sucedió fue que vi algo que
no debía haber visto
algo en el teléfono Ah le revisaste el
teléfono o Lo viste por casualidad no vi
en mi teléfono
espera Qué signo zodiacal eres sí Exacto
Yo también
[Risas]
tienes alguna opinión polémica pues
necesitaré algo más específico la verdad
música cuando lo escuché por primera vez
no entendí Por qué era tan popular Frank
Ocean no voy a mentir
no es bueno
es como Oh Dios mío yo eran por el todos
los días
me gustan mucho y blackpink
baby
pude ir a coachela me hubiese gustado
pero fui a ver a bts esa misma fuiste a
Las Vegas sí Ah Qué envidia iba a ir
pero en vez de eso fui el fin de semana
2 de coche soy de Víctor
yo de Colorado fuera del Estado
Sí para estudiar voy a la ucs
universidad de California en San Diego
tienes que conducir bastante sí sí soy
de la Bahía originalmente Sí eso es una
bandera roja
soy del condado de Orange es como vivir
en una zona de playa
lo que será otra bandera roja porque
somos rivales
[Risas]
ronda 2 deliberación las se eliminarán a
dos mujeres de la cita Jenny no pareces
muy interesante
es que es mi personalidad no sé quizás
es la edad pero es lindo
hay muchas aquí que son mucho mayores
que él entonces
alguna de ustedes cree que hay problema
con la diferencia de edad bueno Tengo 23
soy un poco mayor tiene 19 años
bueno Es probable que ustedes tengan más
cosas en común podrías tenerlas
tienen cosas en común
piensan que quisieran quedarse para la
siguiente ronda creo que estamos
enamorados
ronda 2 eliminación
[Música]
[Aplausos]
Está bien lo esperaba
este punto hay alguien que quiera
eliminarse
soy muy mayor
Adiós ronda 3 citas individuales
las chicas tendrán una cita cara a cara
con Melvin mientras las otras observan
Hola Qué tal Hola listo para terminar
con esto De hecho estoy disfrutando Cómo
estás Todo bien bien Tienes nervios
todavía absolutamente Yo también estoy
nerviosa qué estás estudiando
kinesiología
sí voy a la universidad comunitaria me
dedico a los negocios Sí a los negocios
Sí no sé exactamente a dónde aún pero
Universidad de California la UV tendrías
que mostrarme el lugar
voy a Oakland recuerdas somos rivales lo
sé una bandera roja pero la distancia no
sería un problema Te digo un secreto
soñaba con ir a la upla de verdad
creo que no salí de la lista de espera
pero luego entré una escuela rival y
es terrible a mí me rechazaron de la uss
así
todo el proceso qué dirías que es una
bandera verde bien Bueno tengo una muy
específica si saben cocinar creo que es
muy atractivo
está bien no tienes que saber cocinar
puedo hacer cosas básicas bien poque de
salmón aparte de eso creo que lo más
complicado que he hecho ha sido cereal
bromeo Cuáles son tus hobbies soy
escaladora me gusta estar al aire libre
te asustas las alturas no me da miedo
las alturas pero siento que no sería lo
suficientemente
me gusta mucho tu ropa Gracias tenía
miedo de ponerme las porque no sabía lo
alta que quedaría fue un movimiento
arriesgado la falda de segunda mano
estoy metida en la moda vi tu osito
tienes que ponerle nombre
sinceramente creo que Melvin Junior
La moda es divertida se puede saber
mucho de una persona mirando su ropa
bien el negro es un poco reservado
misterioso pero luego el oso de peluches
como Bueno pues tiene un punto tierno
todo el mundo tiene dos
sabes lo que he querido comprar
recientemente
Cuál prefieres tarantino o nolan
de verdad de verdad las películas de
tarantino muy entretenidas solo me
acuerdo bien cuál es tu película
favorita de nolan quizás hace algo
polémico debí decirlo antes pero
disfruté mucho No de verdad o por Dios
Amén al crecer disfrutaba el anime y te
sigue gustando sinceramente no tengo
tiempo pero Leo mucho manga y estoy
viendo Spy family ahora mismo deberíamos
verla juntos Claro sí quiero saber cuál
es tu nacionalidad soy Chino bien genial
Pero nací aquí en Los Ángeles mi madre
Este China y mi padre creció en Hong
Kong Así que bien soy pero crecí aquí
mis padres son de allí es un lugar que
me gusta mucho de hecho viví un año Qué
te pareció esa experiencia fue muy bueno
fue agradable conocer a gente que es
igual que tú y entrar en contacto con tu
cultura sabes exactamente lo que estás
buscando a largo corto plazo solo por
diversión todavía trato de entenderlo
para ser honesto Yo igual solo llevo 19
años en esta tierra así que me queda
mucho verdad participas en alguna
actividad sí soy embajadora del Campus y
también estoy en un equipo de baile
no eso sería sería muy loco
de acuerdo
Bueno pues aquí vas a enseñarte
[Risas]
eso estuvo genial gracias sí podemos
bailar juntos un día quedan 10 segundos
bueno Qué tal el clima Sí está bien
dijiste que tus padres eran chinos
verdad los míos igual eres cantando sí
canto muy bien
nos vemos Gracias
[Aplausos]
ronda 3 deliberación las chicas deben
votar Quién es la mejor elección para
Melvin bien
Creo que tú de verdad
Creo que está entre reiki Y lo siento
Está entre ustedes dos sí
pienso que ustedes dos chicas hicieron
una buena química pero tu conversación
fue Gracias
última ronda decisión final
[Aplausos]
[Música]
revelación final
las chicas seleccionaron a alguien para
ti bien Estás listo estoy listo confías
en las chicas mi vida seguro
1 2 3 Hola
está sorprendido
lo esperabas o estuvo cerca de verdad Ay
me alegra mucho escucharlo
bien después de la primera ronda tenía a
Esther reging y Briana
y luego en la segunda ronda quién
tenemos
chicas miren es una locura no
[Risas]
cómodo ahora podemos ir claro y tienes
que llevarme a la UFC Gracias ya tiene
nombre el osito es tu nombre ya ganaste
Briana
es un buen nombre muy bien creen que
podrían intercambiar números Instagram
definitivamente
muy bien chicas Eso es todo
cómo te sientes Melvin Muy bien espero
que ella me siento increíble
ver más quieres estar en un video
participa en nuestro casting en la
siguiente dirección suscríbete
[Música]